foreign
this week lawmakers in the U.S House
battled over the debt ceiling
Republicans narrowly passed a bill along
party lines that would raise the debt
limit through March of next year but
with large spending cuts attached
Democrats like House minority leader
Hakeem Jeffrey said going back to 2022
spending levels would harm working
Americans veterans seniors and children
the default on America Act is a ransom
no house ways and means committee
chairman Jason Smith said the Republican
cuts are common sense it puts real
limits on future spending so that we
begin to turn the ship back in a more
fiscally sound Direction it was a weak
chock full of Congressional hearings as
well Republicans examined pandemic
school closures select subcommittee on
the coronavirus pandemic chairman Brad
wenstrip questioned the head of the
American Federation of teachers Randy
Weingarten but despite all this science
aft still wanted to install some way to
automatically close schools
which deviates from The Narrative of
doing everything we can to get them open
Weingarten said she was in touch with
the CDC and consulted doctors on best
practices we know that kids learn best
in person but before all that Americans
heard from President Joe Biden that he
is officially running in 2024 for a
second term while he made it official in
a video he was asked about his
re-election bid while hosting the
president of South Korea specifically
about polling that indicates most don't
want him to run again and many cite his
age as a factor one of the things that
people are going to find out how they're
going to see a race and they're going to
judge whether or not I have or don't
have it I respect them taking a hard
look at it I take a hard look at it as
well I took a hard look at it before I
decided to run while he has two
Democratic Challengers Robert F Kennedy
Jr and author Marion Williamson the
Democratic National Committee has said
they don't plan on hosting debates gosh
there's so many interesting polling
numbers out there on this this week not
surprising Shannon bream is the host of
Fox News Sunday FOX News are new poll
when we ask among Democratic primary
voters who do you want to vote for the
current president gets 62 percent hey
that's solid that's very good but RFK Jr
gets 19 I mean that's almost a fifth of
primary voters are like oh I'm gonna
pick some other guy who probably doesn't
have a real chance of winning that's how
much I don't want my current president
the leader of my party to actually be
the nominee the next time around you
mentioned the age thing you look at the
CBS News polling when they're asked for
reasons and these are people who are
lean Democrat Independents Or democrats
um what are your concerns about and you
why you think he shouldn't run number
one his age number two time for someone
new and number three I like other
Democrats more so I mean his approval
rating is not good any poll that you
look at but there's real consternation
within his own party that they want
someone else they're not happy with him
but listen if he's the guy I don't think
that most Democrats are going to jump
across the aisle and vote for the GOP
nominee the question is whether they
just decide to stay home if there's no
enthusiasm do we see any pivots though
from this President as he campaigns for
a second time in 2024 it sounds like
he's saying just watch me I'll be out on
the campaign Trail
um and you guys can judge for yourselves
but I mean now that he's seen the
polling and we've all seen the polling
does he make himself more visible
available well a lot of people are
wondering about that like how much more
we're going to see from him so we had
this presser with him uh in the South
Korean president who are visiting
um the same week that he's announced but
to really sit there and go at it with
the Press is not something he does very
much I mean he lags way behind all
recent presidents in availability all of
the press Corps is complaining they all
want to see more of this president he's
gonna have to get out there in the
campaign Trail
um listen kovid changed everything in
2020 and running from your basement is
not going to be an option this time so
there will be a real look for voters to
have a chance to see him in action how
he is on the campaign Trail how he is
with people how he is with his grueling
schedule of events well also to be fair
being the leader of the Free World it's
a lot for any person so um I think he's
going to have to get out there certainly
much more than 2020. and this I mean as
we were told earlier this week by a
former Biden surrogate in 2020 you know
he'll he will be president likely still
at that time when he's running and
that's visibility in its own right um
right Shannon the reaction from
Republicans it was very Stark I mean
former president Trump was talking about
like World War III in his reaction
um the RNC had a fully AI generated ad
that was full of very dark dystopian
images I I wonder
was that too over the top or does that
resonate maybe with some persuadables
who maybe feel like things are tenuous
right now with Russia China Banks
inflation you name it yeah you and I
know we've covered this enough that
people will tell you they hate negative
scary ads but then all the data will
show you that they work so people may
say they don't like that stuff but both
sides know that appealing to fear often
people will vote out of that versus a
positive uplifting message this is kind
of what Senator Tim Scott is out there
testing in the field will people respond
to this message of Faith and Hope and
pulling together and counting on each
other and staying away from name calling
and you know I don't know I mean he
feels like he's seen enough he's got
that exploratory committee now but the
fact is the dark fearful ads work
history proves it and for whatever
reason human nature seems to be
persuaded by that you mentioned the Fox
News poll it did as we've noted and
we've seen found former president Trump
with a double-digit lead over Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and and DeSantis
noted while in Japan hey I'm not even a
candidate yet but this poll also found
broadly more people think Banning books
and not being accepting enough of
transgender families are more important
than trans kids competing on girls
sports teams or discussions about race
in the classroom for those like DeSantis
who maybe would focus on those kinds of
issues in a presidential campaign what
do you think he and other Republicans
maybe should glean from this kind of
polling
I think probably DeSantis is one of
these guys who they all say this like I
don't care about polls I mean he really
demonstrated that during covet he was
willing to do what he thought in his
assessment of going through scientific
materials and studies and talking to
experts I mean he'll say I make the
decisions that I believe from my core
the right decisions now in Florida
they've done a lot of this and he won my
19 points after barely squeaking out a
minor percentage fraction of a
percentage point in his initial election
so I think he's going to feel very
emboldened like listen I've got my
finger on the pulse of this stuff the
Floridians who turned out in droves and
basically turned the state from purplish
to solid red what I did in Florida will
work on a national stage I mean that's
what he's been out testing around the
country so
um yes the Florida blueprint right yeah
and I think that he's going to make the
argument that it will work nationally he
knows in some states that's not going to
work those States may be ones that
listen I don't know in my lifetime if
we'll see a Republican presidential
candidate win California or New York
right so you know they may just go ahead
and take those off the table but he
knows in other states and across the
South the Midwest important places the
polling may be very different and he's
willing to I think if he gets in ride
that path and to stand by it a lot of
oxygen taken up on the hill this week
with the debt ceiling debate Republicans
did vote to raise the debt limit along
with a bunch of spending cuts though
that's obviously tied in there it
doesn't seem like it will go anywhere
right a democratic controlled Senate the
president's not going to sign it but I
guess it was meant to show according to
the analysts that that Republicans can
stick together and that the President
should negotiate we don't have much time
it sounds like according to the treasury
secretary so what will the president do
now
well even with his own in his own party
he's got Democrats now saying okay we
understand you know you don't want to
negotiate over the debt ceiling but we
have to do something now you said
Republicans need to put something on the
table they have
uh the speaker against most odds pulled
together enough of these votes to
actually pass something so that gives
him something to go to the table with
like hey you said we need to come
together on something here's what we've
got he knows he's not going to get
everything in there Democrats know
they're probably not going to get
everything in there so the two sides are
going to have to come together I mean
this what the speaker pulled off is to
his credit and the critics who said he
couldn't do it now he has something that
forces the president's hand and when you
have Democrats now publicly calling on
him to say you got to get us together we
at least have to have some kind of
conversations the pressure's on now from
both sides and interesting to me too
that several Senate Republicans have
come out to say like hey we stand with
the house great job by the speaker
because they've kind of hung back and
let him do his thing yes but it cuts off
that Avenue if the White House wanted to
try to go to the Senate GOP directly and
have negotiations with them the Senate
now casting with the house and sporting
What speaker McCarthy did means that the
White House doesn't have that Avenue
got it just a couple more for you we
other than the Congressional debate on
the debt limit we had plenty of hearings
as I'm sure you saw
um and we heard from Randy Weingarten
the head of the American Federation of
teachers took a lot of heat over the
school closures during covid going back
and forth with Republicans in a sort of
high profile hearing and and really
tried to defend herself saying she was
Consulting with doctors in the CDC and
Republicans said her guidance was too
Draconian I guess schools were closed
for too long but I suppose the question
would be out of a hearing like that then
what now let God forbid there's another
pandemic would anything be different did
we learn anything I mean did we learn
anything from this hearing that they've
learned anything about if we have to
Pivot or do something else God forbid we
have another pandemic yeah gosh I think
that people lost so much faith in public
institutions and when you find out that
people were having back Channel
conversations and things that they
played dumb about they had already kind
of negotiated behind closed doors
you know those kinds of things what I
heard from all my mama bear friends this
week who had school-aged children who
were living through this in real time
who are Furious about their kids lost
year or two depending on where they
lived
um and feeling like Randy Weingart now
is coming out and trying to Gaslight
them that's that's the phrase I'm
hearing from some of these Mama friends
who are like listen there were States
who moved forward and had kids in school
there were private schools who had you
know safety structures in place and you
know when there was a positive test they
had you know their own way to handle
this and to you know keep the kids
safely in they feel like she was about
the union and not about the kids and
they feel like she was caught in a lot
of things that weren't especially
transparent and so unfortunately what I
think is if this happens again in our
lifetime heaven forbid that there's
going to be so much skepticism about
following
um you know the teachers unions or
following the CDC or following the White
House no matter who is running those
things
left right or Center I think gosh
parents who lived through the last
couple of years of this very angry and
very skeptical
got a hit on a foreign policy note
before we leave um President Biden as
you noted earlier met with South Korea's
president they pledged to work together
on a number of items especially
concerning our national security and
with North Korea but as that was
happening I guess China's president Xi
Jinping talked to Ukraine's president
for the first time since this War began
and it was reported that she said you
know we don't want to add fuel to the
fire we want to end this war peacefully
and help you do that
do U.S officials buy that and believe
that Xi Jinping or Chinese officials
will not help Russia out in the duration
of this war whatever's left remaining of
it yeah they feel like if that was true
that China didn't want to give any
advantage at all to Russia they would
really crack down on Dual use items like
drones and others that aren't
necessarily lethal Aid or Weaponry but
can be used for the battlefield they
think China needs to be much clearer
about that and they don't like this idea
that China is going around the world
trying to be the mediator of you know
issues in the Middle East now the war in
Ukraine it's the last thing that U.S
lawmakers and leaders in the White House
want is for XI to be now showing up as
if he is the one to bring people
together to bring you know broken
factions together and to be a bomb on
the you know wounds of the world I mean
that's the last thing they want they
don't want to be boxed out of Europe
where he's trying to do it or Africa or
anywhere else so I think the last thing
that they want to see is Xi stepping up
to say I'm the one who's gonna you know
get this thing done although I think
everybody agrees maybe other than Putin
they want this thing over
Fox News Sunday host Shannon bream
thanks for joining great to be with you